[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI:
Hello, everyone.
So today we're going to talk
about deep learning images
for Google Compute Engine.
And this is an
interesting topic.
And the nature of this
topic is interesting.
Many Meetups and many
activities usually
show by the end of
the activity how
to build something,
something new and cool.
But deep learning
images is a tool,
a tool that you have to
use in your own projects.
So probably today
we're not going
to cover one particular cool
thing that you can build.
I will try to explain the tool.
And I hope you guys
will know how to utilize
this tool in your own projects.
So while we're going to speak
about the deep learning images,
from time to time I will be
using different commands that
simplify my life
when I'm working
with deep learning images, and
actually just Google Compute
Engine.
So this is a link
on the GitHub page
that has exactly
all the commands
that I will be showing today.
This link will be in the
followup notes on the Meetup.
So if you don't have a laptop
and don't want to write it
right now, it's absolutely OK.
These are QR codes
on the survey.
But I will show you
survey slightly later.
You will see these
QR codes again.
Let me start with answering
one main question.
What is deep learning images?
So deep learning
images is basically
a set of different
VM images that
has everything that you need
for doing your deep learning
research out of the box.
There are several
key things here.
This is not one image
for a virtual machine.
This is a set of images.
We actually have
different images.
This is a graph that
describes all of them.
And we will come back
to this graph later on.
But just a key point, this
is not just the one image.
The second key point is that
it's working out of the box.
So what does it mean?
And why is it
actually important?
So let's meet Bob.
So this is Bob.
Bob wants to do a deep learning.
To do a deep learning,
he wants to build
his own virtual machine
that has everything that
is needed for deep learning.
In order to do so, if Bob wants
to use TensorFlow and the GPU,
he actually needs
to figure out which
particular version of CUDA
is required by TensorFlow.
If any one of you
in the past have
tried to set up yourself
TensorFlow with CUDA,
you probably do know
that even to figure out
which exact version of
the CUDA is required
is not a simple task.
By the way, how many
of you guys set up
TensorFlow with GPU yourself
on your local machine, Mac OS,
or in the cloud?
OK.
Quite a few.
Good.
So you know the pain.
Next, when you
figure out the CUDA,
you need to know which exact
driver your CUDA is using.
And you need to
install that driver.
Then you can install CUDA.
Then you need to figure out
which exact version of CuDNN
is required by TensorFlow
and install it.
And NCCL-- starting
with TensorFlow 1.10,
it will actually not work if
you're not going to install
the correct NCCL binary.
And then you can finally
install TensorFlow.
And if something goes
wrong, probably it's
not going to work at all.
OK.
So let's say our Bob has
completed the setup of the VM
with several GPUs V100.
And the setup looks like this.
So this is the
exact setup that Bob
has completed, TensorFlow
1.9, CUDA 9.0, CuDNN
7, no NCCL installed.
Reasonable question to ask--
is this the best
possible configuration
that gives you the most out
of the money that you're
paying for the instance?
So let's have a look
for the baseline.
So this is the
baseline of the speed.
This is the configuration that
we just discussed that Bob has.
If you switch to CuDNN
7.1 and the latest NCCL,
you will have a 10%
performance boost
on top of what you had with
the original configuration.
So one may think, OK, let's just
use the latest CUDA, the latest
driver, the latest CuDNN,
and just forget it.
It will give me the
maximum performance.
Even though this thought
may have appeared
when CUDA 9.1 was released, you
can see that 9.1 actually slows
down TensorFlow.
So if you used to
use the latest one,
by the time CUDA
9.1 was out, you
are not using the best
possible configuration.
And now if you're
using the latest 9.2,
you actually have a
15% performance boost.
OK.
How can Bob actually
figure this out?
Which of the
configurations is the best
for his particular instance?
If you want to figure this out,
you need to compile TensorFlow.
There is no other way
to use different CUDAs,
except to compile
it from the source.
The official binary is
using only CUDA 9.0 period.
You cannot use anything else.
Then you need to run experiments
with your particular model
on the instance to figure out
whether this new TensorFlow
that you have compiled actually
gives you any performance
boost.
And you need to build
approximately 12 binaries.
You have three different CUDAs.
You have two different CuDNNs.
You have two different
NCCL options.
And [? Anton's ?] speaking
about using Python 2, Python 3.
So 12 binaries that you
need to compile from source.
And if a new Nvidia
stack is released,
or a new TensorFlow
is released, you
need to start all
this from scratch.
Because performance actually
does change with a new stack.
And this is exactly where
my team comes into play.
We are focusing
precisely on figuring out
which particular configuration
of deep learning framework
will squeeze maximum
performance out of the hardware
that we have on the
Google Compute Engine.
So we're trying to figure
out with each particular new
release how to compile it so
you will get the maximum out
of your money.
If we compare what we
have on the Google Compute
Engine within our images
to the official TensorFlow
that you can just download,
you will see the difference
with CUDA.
We're using 9.2, while
TensorFlow has 9.0.
We have the same CuDNN.
We're using NCCL.
Actually 1.10 [INAUDIBLE]
also starts using NCCL.
We're using MKL.
MKL just for CPU instances.
And even if you don't
know what MKL is,
MKL on non GPU instances
can give you up
to fives times
performance boost.
Like five times
is just crazy when
you have something that
works that fast comparing
the official build.
OK.
So this is what you get
inside of the images,
already prebuilt, configured,
and ready to work.
Now, one may ask where these
deep learning images fit
among all our other products.
We have Kubeflow.
We have Machine Learning Engine.
We have Colab and all
other different things
that we're providing
on the market.
So if you look on this magical
line of different products,
let's say the left-most side
is a fully managed solution,
something like Machine
Learning Engine, or Colab.
And the right-hand
side is a solution
that you have in your data
centers, your machines.
And basically somewhere over
there on the right-ish side,
we have Google
Compute Engine, where
you can spin up the machine,
do whatever you want.
And probably somewhere there we
have Kubeflow with Kubernetes.
It's not entirely fully
managed, because you still
have access to
the machine on GCE
even if you're
running Kubernetes.
And let me show you the
quote of this nice guy.
And also who remembers
what was this quote about?
Who remembers this quote at all?
It's an old quote.
It's OK.
OK.
I see one hand.
AUDIENCE: Google Search.
When people were mistyping
their Google searches.
VIACHESLAV KOVALEVSKYI: Close.
But actually maybe
he said it twice.
Who knows.
But one thing that,
when he mentioned
this is, when Google Cloud
was initially released we
had only one offering.
We had App Engine.
App Engine was a
really nice technology.
It was the first serverless
technology on the market
out there.
But the thing is that
the customers were not
entirely ready.
They did not have
resources to invest,
to move all in at
that time on the brand
new, new approach that
they never had seen before.
So then Eric Schmidt
mentioned that, OK, yes,
we do have this bright future.
But we also need to meet our
customer where they are now.
And then Google Cloud actually
introduced Google Compute
Engine.
So this is where our deep
learning images are right now.
They're in the spot where
you have your own solution.
You have your own
research files, logic.
You have your own spin up
cluster solution that you do
not want or cannot right
now to move anywhere.
You cannot invest right now.
But you have a lot of legacy.
You need to run it somewhere.
So if you do need to run it with
TensorFlow or with GPU, just
GPU, you are our
customers, because we
will produce the best
image that can handle it.
OK.
How to use it?
We have several ways
to use our images--
actually two main
possible usages.
We are the UI or the CLI.
UI is pretty simple
and self exploratory.
I'm not going to
actually touch that part.
I will focus on CLI, Common
Line Interface, and the stuff
that you need to know.
So the first thing
that you need to do
if you want to create an
instance with deep learning
image is figure out
which particular flavor
you want to use.
This is a graph of
the current flavors
that we are providing right now.
So as you can see,
we're supporting
two major frameworks,
TensorFlow and PyTorch.
And if you need something
custom, anything else,
literally, that
requires CUDA, we
have common flavors with
different versions of CUDA.
So first of all, we
need to figure out
which particular
flavor you want to use.
This is also called
image family.
In this particular
example we're using family
TensorFlow latest with CUDA 9.2.
This is where
family is specified.
And how many of you
guys are creating,
have created, have played with
instances on Google Compute
Engine, or any other cloud
providers in the past?
Quite a few.
Good.
So if you create an instance
in Google Compute Engine,
you have this ability to
specify a family of the images.
You can think about family
if you have used Docker tag.
That always points to the latest
particular Docker Container.
And the reason why
I stopped here,
I want to speak
about the problem
with using image family or
Docker Containers' tags.
The thing is, if you're
always pointing at the latest,
there are chances that
something like this
will come up eventually.
This is NumPy community,
that they're basically
broadcasting to the world that
they're releasing a new NumPy.
And this new NumPy has
introduced a lot of, a lot of,
a lot of cleanups.
And this may impact
a lot of customers.
And I actually do
know customers who
got impacted because
of this updated NumPy,
precisely this one.
If you're using
family, or if you're
using Docker Container latest,
probably the latest update
already includes this NumPy
because of the security fixes
that this NumPy has.
And it probably will break you.
So if you're using either
Docker or our images,
you probably need to switch
from using family directly
on your production to using
the following pipeline.
It's three steps.
You're getting the latest
image from the family.
You're testing it
with your solution.
And then you're
using it in prod.
Always like this-- please,
never use family directly
if you're using it
on the production.
Production doesn't mean
something that serves traffic.
For me today production is my
demo that I'm going to show.
And for my demo, I'm going to
use a particular exact image.
There is a command that
allows you to extract
exactly the image name.
And for today I'm going to
use TensorFlow latest CPU
and exact hash.
This is the image that
basically I'm going to use.
And now I am switching
my command from family
to actual name.
Second one-- Image project.
We have some customers
who actually,
when they're
creating an instance,
are setting projects
to their project.
But this is a project that
hosts the images, which is ours.
Maintain policy.
The thing is, if
you're using GPU,
your instance cannot be live
migrated to another hardware
machine.
This is very important.
And you need to know this
in taking it into account.
If you're using GPU in
case of maintenance,
the only way is to actually
terminate the instance.
The next part, if you want
to create an instance,
you're setting up how or
what that accelerator is then
that you want to use.
This is the important
part, because you
need to not only choose
a particular accelerator
from the four that we have.
You need to educate yourself
about the regions that
exist there.
If you're specifying
the wrong region
where an accelerator doesn't
exist, it will not work.
And after setting
the correct region,
the correct
accelerator, you need
to set up the correct
amount of accelerator
that you will attach
to the instance.
If the amount does
not exist, again,
you cannot create the
instance with, for instance,
a tesla v100, and
four tesla v100s.
We do not support this
configuration yet.
And the last one--
this part is basically
giving permission to Google
on your behalf to install
the Nvidia driver.
The thing is, images come with
pre-installed CUDA, CuDNN.
Everything's pre-set
up and tested,
except the Nvidia driver.
There are some reasons why
it has been done this way.
I am not going to dive into
that particular reason.
But without this flag you will
not have the Nvidia driver
on the instance installed.
Now, what else can you tune?
You can set the preemptible
flag if you need.
Preemptible is basically--
Who knows the concept of
preemptible instances?
OK.
So Google Compute
Engine had this concept
of preemptible instances,
where you are actually buying
the same instance, but
for the cheaper price,
with only one downside.
This instance can be switched
off at any point of time.
So yes.
I personally, any time that I'm
writing preemptible instances,
and then training a
lot of models there,
but from time to time, it might
be switched off without any--
how do you say it?
Anyway.
Now, keep in mind that
you have a quota when
you're creating a GPU.
So you need to request a quota.
Quota for preemptible instances
are not equal to quota
to normal instances.
If you have a quota
for Nvidia P100,
you do need to have a quota
for a preemptible Nvidia P100s
in order to start
preemptible instances.
Next, if you're going to
run the command like this,
you will get the smallest
possible instance.
I think this guy has one core
and less than 1 GB memory.
So if you want you can attach
any supported machine type.
Next, you have the ability
to set up a type of the disk.
This is actually SSD.
We do have support of local SSD
disk, which are way faster--
SCSI disk.
This is basically some of the
measurements and the speed
that we can guarantee you
with the local SSD disk.
And most importantly, we
have introduced a new type
of local SSD disk that
is actually using an NVMI
connection to the instance.
And it gives you--
so the one on the top with the
old one, the one on the bottom
the new one--
I wouldn't say twice faster,
but significantly faster,
which is important
if you are training
something that requires
reading data from the disk.
And the last one.
Scopes.
These scopes are
actually required
if you want to use TPUs.
And here I'm actually
going to switch for just
a second to the console.
I'm going to create a TPU node.
I'm going to create a TPU
node because we're going
to use it in several minutes.
And since it takes to create
a TPU node several minutes,
let me just start my
TPU node right now.
And let me press set up a
network, and press Create.
Now, when you are specifying
these metadata that I just
mentioned, installing
Nvidia drivers through,
you're giving
permission for Google
to install a driver for you.
And a lot of the customers
who actually have a cluster
with many machines
in the cluster,
they are kind of critical
for the time to boot.
If you have four machines, each
of the four machines has eight
worth of V100s, and you have
time to boot equal to three
minutes, you're already
paying for 12 minutes-- yeah,
four machines--
12 minutes just for boot time.
So one of the common
questions is, OK,
how can I reduce time of
the boot for my machine?
And the answer is simple.
We are getting the image that
you want to create instances
from from the Google Cloud.
We can create a deep
learning instance.
We're waiting until the
driver is installed--
three to five minutes.
It's horrible.
We're working on this.
And this will be improved--
stopping the instance, and
creating our own deep learning
image out of that instance.
That simple, five steps and
you have your own image.
And that image will have this
famous 15-second startup time
that GCE gives you
in other images.
OK.
Now, the main part.
Let's actually see
how we can use it.
First, I will show
you Jupyter Lab.
Who have used here Jupyter
Notebooks or Jupyter Lab?
Nice.
So the most important
part is Jupyter Lab.
So let's actually create
the instance and use it.
So I have copy,
pasted one command.
Exactly the command that I just
just showed you on the slides.
Let me make it bigger, bigger,
bigger, bigger, bigger.
So I have my image.
I have the instance name.
I have zone.
Let's go and create it.
Let's wait.
It should take maybe 20
seconds or half a minute max,
because this is a CPU instance.
It's not going to install
the Nvidia driver.
This is a command that I
originally showed to you.
This part is not required
if you are not using GPUs.
So basically this
is the end command.
OK.
Let's see if the
instance showed up.
Nope.
Usually it's faster,
30 or 40 seconds.
OK.
While we are waiting, this
is a small improvement,
one of the commands that I
mentioned to you on my GitHub.
A command that allows you
to SSH to the instance.
It's just slightly
nicer to the, say,
gssh instead of
gcloud compute ssh
and then the name
of the instance.
Just a small
improvement that you
will find on the GitHub page.
In order to connect
to the instance,
you will have to run this gssh
INSTANCE_NAME, specify zone
and the port mapping.
This is the only
one thing that you
need to do after your
instance is up in order
to start using Jupyter Lab.
Instance is up.
So let's actually do it.
Let me copy, paste my command.
We're connecting
to the images live.
Let's go to the browser.
Let's open local host, 8080.
And here is Jupyter.
You have a Jupyter if you would
create the instance with GPU.
You will have GPU with V100.
You literally don't
need to do anything else
except start your instance.
We're already spinning
up the Jupyter
in the background that is
listening on the port 8080.
The only thing that
is left to do for you
is actually to
open your browser.
That's literally it.
Now, next use case.
The next use case is the Colab.
Who have used Colab?
OK.
So for those of you who have
not, let me show what Colab is.
Colab is the Google
Service, that basically
is a notebook in the cloud.
It's very similar
to the notebooks.
It actually provides
a similar use case,
but it's completely hosted.
So you don't have
a machine behind.
But this creates
some implications.
Let me show you exactly
the implications.
So if you have a
Google Cloud project,
and you have your machine,
you have TPU inside,
and you want to use it
with the Colab, you cannot,
because the Colab doesn't have
any notion about Google Cloud
project.
It does not understand that you
have a Google Cloud project.
It cannot connect to
any resources there.
However, you do have a laptop.
And your laptop does
have a connection
to your instance with
port mapping 8080
that we just saw,
precisely for the reason
of opening Jupyter Lab.
And your instances do
have a connection to TPU.
So now the last
part that is missing
is to connect Colab to
your laptop on port 8080.
And this is exactly
the functionality
that we have released
several weeks ago.
We now have the ability to
use our deep learning images
as a back end for the Colab.
And it works very, very simply.
Let me go back to the Colab.
So this is an official Colab.
Let me increase the font.
Let me double check that
this is official Colab.
Let's see the version
of the TensorFlow
that's actually installed here.
It's doing something.
And I hope it
eventually will work.
It should be 1.9.
Yes, it's 1.9, because it's the
official version of the cloud.
Now, let me press Connect
to the Local Runtime.
Basically what this will
do is it will connect Colab
to my local runtime.
And the port is 8080.
And my machine right
now on the port 8080
has a mirror of the port
8080 of the deep learning VM
instance that we had.
Let me press Connect.
That's it.
Now the Colab is
using remote machine.
And, therefore, we will have
TensorFlow 1.9 that we just
have released in our
VM images yesterday,
together with TensorFlow 1.10.
So yes, 1.10, by the
way, got released,
if you haven't been
following on the news.
This basically means,
so now you can use Colab
with anything you
want, including
PyTorch, any possible
GPU, and even TPUs.
Since, as I said, now that
we're using deep learning
image as a back end, let me
create a brand new notebook
in the Colab.
And just to show that we do
have a TPU, access to the TPU,
I will run one cell.
And we can run it here.
Only one cell, that
will connect to the TPU.
Let me first get my IP address.
Oh, the same, 10.0.101.
Yes.
It's the same.
It's actually connected.
So it works.
So now you can use
Colab with the TPU.
As I said, you can
do whatever you
want in Colab with deep
learning images, PyTorch,
any possible GPUs.
Now, another question
that we usually
have from the customers
for the VM images
is how do I do Anaconda?
I want to use Anaconda.
And this is nice.
The Anaconda scenarios
have some problems.
And the reason for this problem,
if you install Anaconda,
if you're creating a new virtual
environment inside of Anaconda,
you need to install TensorFlow
within that environment.
How do you do this?
If you're going to install
official TensorFlow,
it will not work, because
official TensorFlow requires
CUDA 9.0, and we have 9.2.
In order to support
this, we are actually
providing a binary, our Google
Compute Engine optimized binary
that are pre-baked
inside of the image.
So you will have the
ability to install them.
So this is a small
script that we
do have in the official
documentation that
are basically citing
the path where
we're pre-baking the binary.
And then you just can run deep
install inside of your Anaconda
environment.
OK.
Next, how you can get
help if you're stuck.
We have many different
channels to support you guys.
We do have official
docs, of course.
But if you want
something else, I
have several blogs where I'm
actively adding different use
cases for our images.
We do have a dedicated
StackOverflow tag, which
we are actively monitoring.
Please do submit
questions there.
We do have a pretty
active Google Group
with different users
who might help you,
even before I or my colleague
will spot the question.
You can always ping me,
even on personal Twitter.
I would really
appreciate any questions.
You can send me a
mail, and I will answer
any possible ways for you guys.
OK.
In short overview,
deep learning images
is the pre-baked images
that have everything
ready to start with different
ideas, Jupyter Lab, Jupyter
Notebook, Colab back end,
and almost any framework
that you can imagine.
Now, this is the survey, which
is really, really important.
If you can, guys,
help us to understand
what you want to see in the
future version of the VM
images, what you want us to
add as a unit test, which
case scenario you want
us to support, please
do participate in this survey.
Thank you.
Then this is all
from my side, guys.
Thank you for coming.
I hope there is more
pizza still left.
And I hope to see you next time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]